People watching from YouTube and Twitch too, guys.
Hi.
Looking directly at you.
You in the front.
I see you.
Oh, wait.
All right.
Wait, wait, wait.
How are you seeing this?
Welcome.
Oh, my God.
We actually did it in time and everything.
Oh, yeah, we did.
I'm so proud of ourselves.
We're just that good.
We're professional.
by the way we didn't rehearse this at all this was a first
try you're in good hands yeah oh my new role models i swear
i'm responsible i'm a responsible adult i promise i mean
that's why we're captains right oh let's hope so well
welcome new members to the wildcard club orientation You
know, seeing this huge stage pack with all of you guys say
makes my heart just want to burst.
Maybe see a doctor for that.
Maybe calm down just a bit.
It's good to be enthusiastic, but you know, when the Grinch
heart grew 10 times the size and you're like, that's not,
that's not good.
Don't burst, no.
That's a medical condition right there.
like but what isn't a medical condition is seeing all of you
out here today god i'm so good take two take two cut cut
let's try this again ring all right take two and action oh
you want me to oh i'm the wildcard club now oh cool that's
all you understand now this is serious
Okay.
All right.
Mama Lee.
You're dead.
All right.
Welcome, welcome guys to the Wired Caller Club.
We are the four captains and we're so excited to introduce
you to the club because starting today you guys are all
members, whether you're there in Offkai in person in the
crowd or watching on YouTube or Twitch.
Whether you like it or not, yeah, no backsees.
It was in the terms of service.
You checked it.
Sorry, you're already in the first.
you walked into this room and you sealed your fate i'm sorry
locked now you live here you cannot escape we'll be handed
out soon all right all right okay all right no more no more
distractions guys we only have less than an hour left of
this room before they kick us out so we got so much news
lined up today so we are getting excited i doubt anyone came
here well knowing who we are but uh if by any chance is your
first time meeting us head over to the wildcard club on
YouTube channel and catch up from episode one.
Yeah.
We did it on YouTube and everything.
Leave some comments.
Give it some love.
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
Yeah, there's us.
That's all of us.
It's time to get to know your clubmates, guys.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Look at our cute little cards.
We're going to be playing a little game today, guys.
It's like Jay saw.
Play a little game.
We're going to be playing a little game.
We're going to get...
You want to play a game?
Yeah.
me until we play with me we didn't say we locked the room
only one will be able to find out which of you is the
wildest of them all yeah it's like a battle royale it's like
only one member can join the wild today's no no no no it's
an innocent fun game that we can get to know you and you can
participation and have we're gonna play something called
never have i ever uh unfortunately we don't have alcohol
with us today so unfortunately no we're gonna play this game
uh in a way where if you're in the audience you can raise
your hand if you have if you never played never have i ever
it's like uh never have i ever done this or done that um and
then if you've done it you gotta take a shot but like but we
don't do that that's the family friendly club yeah so we're
gonna raise our hands in the audience instead which is
basically as good as taking shots yeah so if you've done it
you raise your hand guys and on you if you're on youtube and
twitch use the raise hand emoji too so we know we know
you've done if you're in my chat spin just spin for your
lives uh all right uh as the first icebreaker we're gonna do
a really easy one to get you into it this is never have I
ever played never have I ever okay so we're already met a
game again like am I welcome so it's almost my idea you're
welcome you're welcome I'm gonna have to start spinning I
don't know how do I spin if you've played the game if you're
in the audience raise your hand raise your hand oh my god
how do you do that oh I'll never tell you what I learned
once that I forgot or do we If you have, if you have.
Putting your hand up is perfectly adequate.
I feel like I need to say this.
If you're an off guy right now, you don't need a spin.
You don't get to spin.
Wait, do I see anyone raising their, is anyone raising their
hand?
Wait, nobody's raising their hand.
Oh, yeah.
They had to be told.
Spin your hands.
Dislocate your wrists.
Yeah, time for day march.
Wave around.
Actually, wave around.
It's actually a lot easier to see.
Yeah, yeah.
Wow.
lot of people a lot of people have got wild today what if
you don't know if you played it or not no yeah one hand one
hand raise your elbow right all right next question or the
other never have i overs we're gonna never have i ever
searched myself online oh all right well you ever googled
yourself to be like what does google know what does the
internet know about me
well okay have you got legal search yourself guys well i've
searched myself but it wasn't okay so like yeah i searched
myself because somebody asked me for png and i was and i
didn't have png so i i've definitely searched up my own art
references before i'm like where is where's the art
reference oh there it is from google images what about what
about you so you have you guys didn't spin why was mine i
don't know how to spin what can i do oh i'm gonna hold up
i'm gonna hold this up wait i'm gonna wait rin you've never
searched yourself online oh yeah i was gonna say there's no
way i'm the only one there's no way we're all streamers here
there's no way what about the audience have you guys ever
searched yourself raise your hand in in off guy yeah oh a
lot of you have oh okay nice you yes yeah i still have my
fans we love it that's why all right yeah question three
what's to do question three question three never have i ever
been in a club before are we thinking the physical location
like the organizational structure
with your friends or like in school or like yeah i'll spend
my i'll do club i've been in a club i was a president for a
club too oh that's a that's a linear dog oh well you know
foreshadowing the gun foreshadowing i think i've been in a
club i don't i think i've been in a club uh well you're in a
club now yeah you have you've been in a club now that's all
that matters oh yeah club iron true it has club at the end
if club i and mouse counts does club penguin count that
counts that counts if you ever played club penguin start
raise your hands personally i'm still on topic we're still
on topic personally i think this is a trick question because
at the beginning we said everyone is a member now of the
club so technically as of five minutes ago you are a member
of a club so everyone should be the game was raising their i
agree i agree show of hands you're all you're all here now
george rock remember again whether you like it or not
whether you like it or not all right next question mm-hmm
who hasn't said it yet who hasn't read this one mouse yeah
yeah never have i ever visited the wild card clubhouse
before the orientation ah wow have you guys been to the the
booth yeah did you see our lockers yeah and all of the stuff
that we forced people to buy for us well my locker well the
only thing i made them buy was the faker plushie i when i
showed the photo of my locker everyone was like please
address the elephant in the locker which was trust me yes
please go on which was um the minions uh solasky crystal of
course this again this again this is my locker yeah after
all this time i remember being with my chat and i was like
guys look there's a minions crystal i can't who would buy
this and it's you don't see i'm the target animal that's me
that's kind of beautiful i'm not gonna lie so here's another
thing next to the minion solasky crystal which was the dogen
that i showed you guys and so i also gave them a little mini
confessional booth um because i've joked about buying there
was a little confessional booth that i bought uh got saw in
a store one day and if you press a button the lights will
glow in the confessional booth and then the godly voice will
pop up saying you are forgiven and then they place the
confessional booth next to the yaoi dojin as oh i don't know
that's how well it's necessarily but sure actually art i i
think that's installation art i didn't even tell them to
place it like that.
It just, they just, they knew what they.
I knew.
Here we are.
Well, if you're at Offkai and you have not seen this
beautiful piece of art, you can go over and check out the
wildcard club booth.
We have standees that you can go take photos of.
You can write on our wall.
You can take photos of our locker and look at all of our
cool things.
And if you're not there in person.
Yeah, if you're not there in person, you can always like put
a photo of like your your PNG.
You can pretend you with that yeah there's like a little
decorate your locker thing that they're doing over there too
like with like the stickers and stuff too so yeah please
make sure to check out the wildcard clubhouse booth after
the orientation you haven't already yeah all right all right
next slide sir yeah oh yeah i thought yeah okay we're gonna
keep it rolling we're gonna switch over so that we learned
about you but now you're going to learn about us yes feeling
very seen in that Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go left to right for these.
Okay.
Your left on my left.
Your left.
Wait, my left.
So me?
I'm a lead.
Yeah.
So me?
So me.
I was left.
Okay.
I got it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Left.
All right.
I'm going to leave you first.
Okay.
Never have I ever been a captain before for something.
All right.
Do you guys think I have?
Oh, wait.
I guess I'm not for fun now.
Do I give captain energy?
Do you know what I'm saying?
give captain energy you do i have been a captain before i've
been a captain for two sports i was a captain for uh varsity
softball and uh volleyball actually oh my gosh team captain
my mom actually got me my class ring is inscribed with team
captain oh my gosh that's so cute that's so cool yeah she
was so happy team captain anyways what about what about uh
Do you want to do one each for us or?
There are four.
I mean, I don't know how many.
We have four.
So we should just go to the next one.
We got to keep it rolling.
Well, we'll have Rindu the next one.
Never have I ever instantly clicked with Solon just because
we shared the same intro.
Depends what you refer to as an interest, I suppose.
I mean, I've seen that happen in real life.
I've seen that remember.
I saw that.
It's happened.
Oh, you should tell the story.
Tell that story.
What happened in Korea?
you've got to be more specific than that we were all having
dinner together we had dinner so many times john dokey barge
at the place you know the place yeah yeah you know when we
did the stuff you know what was the what was the theme what
was the what did we talk about we're like written was i
think it was google translate i think it was less of an
interest you're all thinking of when we ran into someone who
didn't speak like conversational English but did speak
Japanese and I managed to like power Japanese my way through
a conversation with them.
And you guys were so impressed by my actual like second
grade level of language capability.
Yeah, because you guys were talking to the translator and
you guys were bonding and everything.
I was like, that's so cute, you know?
It was beautiful.
And then Emily and I were getting drunk.
Meanwhile, on the other side of the table, yeah.
So we're like, yeah, it's fine, he is.
It was just so cute because we were all quiet because we
didn't know what to say because we couldn't communicate.
So it was just like this long pause of silence.
Move aside, boys.
I'm Nihongo Jozu.
And then you in like rapid fire Japanese went .
And then she went .
And I was like, okay, she's got this.
One's got this.
Another soju, please.
Two more.
Oh, no.
All right.
Apparently we have got to keep going.
Okay, next question will be Mouse.
Never have I ever lost sleep last night because I was too
excited to meet you all.
Very specific.
This feels targeted.
Wait, that happened to you today, technically.
That is true.
I only slept one hour because I was so excited.
Yeah.
You could not tell, though.
You could not tell.
And that's why the rest of this panel is going to be nap
time.
Everyone together now.
It's sleep in chat, guys.
And they're like, wait, we still don't know what the
wildcard club is.
Hey, wait a second.
I know you'll never know.
Oh, no.
All right.
Question four for Doki.
Never have I ever felt this.
Okay.
That's definitely specifically to me.
Every copy of this PowerPoint presentation is personalized.
It got some fun chaos as a cast.
I feel like this entire panel has already been me derailing
stuff.
I got you, don't we?
We've only got like one wheel of the four on the rails.
still it's a miracle we're going in the right direction
we're derailing and they're like guys come on we gotta wrap
it up we gotta we see explain the wildcard club yeah we'll
get there all right i think i think that's good we we did it
we played never ever the panel's over we can all go home
what do you mean there are most slides the entire panel guys
see you all right or it would be if not fall there we go
what is the wildcard club who's been waiting for all right
who wants to explain it i'll do it i'll do it i'll do it uh
this is an open club it's a welcoming space where every
creator has a place uh it's a shared journey a collective
group um it's just a cool place where you guys can hang out
and we can, like, create music together.
It is a hideout designed for VTubers to freely express
themselves.
And it's a welcoming space for everyone to do their own
thing and write their own new stories on their own terms.
So there is no limitation.
The sky is the limit sort of thing.
There's a project and there's, like, four teams, which is,
you know, that's why there's four captains.
There's four teams.
And there's no ranking, no winning, no...
just we're just creating music that's it for the game it's
not a competitive thing we're not competing against each
other we're just making music just so you guys know as much
as apparently doki wants to throw hands with everyone in the
room it's not that it's like a challenge you know like what
was that like the the acapella movie group what was it
called and then what you're talking about yeah and they do
like acapella riff offs and stuff where they just start like
doing one-on-one gang songs.
It's literally just a fun club for fun.
It is not not an agency or a training like system or
anything.
It's literally just a fun.
It's just a fun music project.
Yeah.
This is the fun after school club, not the school.
Yes.
Exactly.
All right.
Next slide, please.
I think we should go left and right again.
I think that's me.
Yeah, who can be a club member?
Hi, I'm the guy in the group project who's just reading off
the PowerPoint presentation.
Oh, God.
But basically, the whole deal about the Wildcard Club is
basically anything goes.
If you want to be in the Wildcard Club, congratulations.
You've already done it.
You didn't even realize you're just that smart.
We're all so proud of you.
But it is, I would describe it personally as a collective
framework led by four captains where in each unit naturally
brings their own energy to produce and release four original
tracks.
Wow.
Four original songs?
Four of them.
Yeah, yeah.
Four original tracks, you say.
Like our debut songs for our groups and everything.
Songs, infinite songs, four songs.
Yeah, just four songs.
No, there might be more.
There might be more at four.
There might be more.
There might be more, but we're gonna start off with four.
Mm-hmm.
I don't even rhyme as well.
God, she's good.
Next slide.
Next slide, please.
We'll have Mals take this one.
I guess that's me.
Well, how do we play through music?
Well, for us, music is how we bond and naturally express
what we love the most.
So making it the ultimate tool to play together, we're
amplifying our distinct colors and stories and we get to
deliver them louder to a wider and broader audience with you
guys.
i mean we've we've already spoken a little bit about um the
what the kind of themes for the songs are gonna be uh so
doki you said you were going to do like a girl band thing
like it's like punkish rockish so cool stuff yeah so it
really is just like express yourself wow expressing yourself
experience music yeah what we want to do all right so now
it's your song now you guys are we're wondering who is the
secret big global music company that's behind us Who is with
us?
The secret.
Who's with us?
Who did this?
Who's responsible?
Drum roll, please.
Hi.
So for those who don't know, Hive, do you know BTS?
That's right.
Question's over.
Thank you for coming out.
So, so Hive stands behind this project as a global podcast.
powerhouse, bridging creators and cultures to bring this
club to life.
Hive has connected four captains creating, which is all four
of us, creating a shared space where our individual talents
can collide and multiply.
Beyond just setting a stage, Hive provides backing for
original music and visual content, offering the structure
and resources needed to bring our ideas directly to life and
share them with the world.
Yes, that's why we were in Korea.
That's right.
We got a tour and everything.
It's cool.
You guys ever just wonder, like, how do we get here?
This seems like a bit of a step up.
That's true.
I was just like, what?
It is so cool.
Okay, sure.
Why not?
So thank you very much to Hive for bringing us together in
this opportunity to be a bunch of little weirdos.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I'm so honored to be a part of this.
Yeah, truly.
It's such a cool.
It's so surreal to me.
That's what I was saying when I was just like, I was like,
this can't be a real email.
You know, like, genuinely I think like, we got email my end.
I was like, this is definitely a scam.
And then my manager was like I was talking to my manager and
apparently this is legit.
And we were like, oh, okay.
I believe it till I was in Korea.
And I'm like, maybe this is legit.
Maybe this is real, real.
Like even like whilst you're on the plane right there, like,
that's not where.
building.
We're in the hive building.
And I was like, guys, I think we're in hive.
I think we're here.
I think we're here, guys.
Oh my gosh.
All right.
So cool.
So should we talk about what we're actually doing?
You know, what hives for us together to actually be doing?
How will you, how can you get involved basically for the
wild card club?
All right.
Left to right.
Left to right again, I guess.
All right, we will be recruiting new members who will form
groups with our captains, which is me, Doki, Mouse, and Rin,
obviously.
We're going to have a little QR code up here in the minute
where you guys can go to apply to be a part of our club.
It is four units formed around our four captains.
The units will launch full-scale music activities, each
creating a distinct music style that we talked about um and
this uh production will be backed uh by hive uh which is
really really cool and awesome um rin do you want to go next
uh well the main thing that we got to mention right now is
that you can apply apply now do it do it do it do it it is
open to any if you're a vtuber congratulations you can apply
you can do it application is going to be open until august
28th Don't worry if you're not like the best singer in the
world, because like Rin Panera has gone on to the project,
so anything's possible.
We're not just looking for like real good singers, although
looks at Amalie, they're allowed in.
We're looking for people who are just- You don't have to be
an incredible singer, don't worry.
If you've got a passion for it, and if you've got like a
story you want to tell.
Oh yeah, just I forgot to mention this part, but just to
reiterate, the wildcard club isn't a training school or a
coaching program so like we're not coaching you guys by the
way in fact if you're in my team you might have to coach me
um this is a massive responsibility cool music with you
that's it yeah yeah yeah so it's just us making a music
together and hive is providing that part platform and
resources so and we're trying to bring a lot of talented
creators to come together to make lots of fun music yeah
yeah yeah oh but um even if you on a vtuber if you have a
creative mind or there are ways that you too can participate
if you're interested in art animation thumbnail creation or
merch design for an upcoming content please send us an intro
email and you know just tuning in and participating makes
you a massive wild card just like us i think that's really
it right from this part of the portion of the panel
we got oh yeah and oh yeah i know it's not a competition but
now we have to go to war we have to pitch ourselves when
you're applying you're picking a captain that you want to
join too so like it's not like i won't join any of them you
just you have to uh choose one choose the one of us who
makes a choice guys if you're applied to be part of a team
to any of the youtubers out there you got to pick i think
there's like second choice as well right i don't remember
it's If you join my team, you're going to have no scuff
ever, obviously.
It's a promise.
I'm sorry.
It was mean to laugh, though.
See, I didn't apologize.
Oh, no.
All right.
Next slide, Maestro.
Yes, please.
Oh, wait.
We're already here.
Oh, we're too good.
I didn't even realize we were here.
already oh my god um but wait it's mousy's turn it's my turn
yeah it's your turn oh my god wait no you did last time
sorry i lost track i'm sorry make me go again huh yeah i
almost got you i almost skipped my turn it's like oh no um
but yes if you guys like signed up for the Captain Custom T.
Lucky draw.
We are going to be announcing live right now here on this
panel.
Who's going to win the Captain Custom T-shirts live on the
OBS roulette wheel?
Whoa.
So there's going to be a total of four winners and will be
selected.
One winner per Captain's shirt.
Each captain will pick a winner for their own custom
T-shirt.
When a captain says stop, the on-site tech operator will
click the roulette button to draw the winning ticket number
um and winners must be here on site i'm sorry to people on
youtube and twitch you can watch this though it's gonna be
so unless you can phase through the screen in which case
we'll all be impressed yeah if or you get proxy over there
they call up a friend like i got the shirt pretend you're me
right now um if their number is called they must raise their
hand captains um yeah we have us captains will ask the
runner to raise their hand or a number is called and they
will receive a prize from the staff after the panel is over
before they leave the room.
And we'll give you one minute to raise your hand.
If nobody raises their hand, we will pick another number.
So just so you guys know, you have to be here.
One minute, have I ever?
So taking shots is not a substitute for raising your hand
when your number gets picked.
I feel like I should just say that now.
If you want, you got your name drawn.
Please don't.
All right, next.
All right, where's the wheel?
Give us the wheel.
Give me the wheel now.
Left to right, guys.
As always.
My left, though, you're left.
It's Amelie's left.
Amelie's left.
My left.
All right.
Spin that wheel.
I'm a shirt.
My shirt.
Who's going to wear my shirt?
I feel like someone fabulous.
it oh now i got frame it i guess 255 where are you where are
you there number 255 will the real 255 please stand up
please stand up please stand up i see you're gonna go oh you
can raise your hand show us proof though don't be like i
definitely have 200 are you real are you 255 get a pencil
cross on your number and write 255 Yay!
Enjoy.
Take care of her, please.
Keep her safe.
No scuff.
That's going to pay for your children's college.
Get me to sign it.
Oh, yeah.
It's going to be on eBay tomorrow.
No!
Well, moving swiftly on to someone who won't sell my shirt
at auction.
Let's do rinsed shirts.
Yeah, rinsed, rinsed.
Rinsed shirt time.
Rachel, wait just for the wheel please.
Would you like to buy a vowel?
What is this countdown?
Who is it?
John 252!
252!
I think that was 252 people named John in this audience.
My god.
Are you here?
Oh yeah, people who are watching from stream, they don't see
it.
So they're like, don't worry, we can see it.
see them if you watch you on twitch imagine this in your
mind right yeah just imagine this happening in your mind
right now there's a wheel yeah this is definitely happening
where people are receiving the shirts are receiving them i
swear they're real yeah the two of these people are claiming
did we get it we got it i think so oh no i think so all good
you need to you need to roll like a three now to prove that
it's not right exactly okay okay it's time for my shirt
Who's going to win my shirt?
Spin the wheel, spin the wheel.
I hope you like ruffles.
They're going to love ruffles.
95!
A double digit number.
95, 95, 95.
I wish we do have a t-shirt cannon.
And then we go.
That would be so fun.
Next time.
We'll get it for next years off, Kai.
Next time we bring t-shirt cannons, just start ripping it
into the crowd.
number 95 are you there are they there are they receiving
the shirt what would you're like outside the panel room
being like i think they called my number let me just gotta
pop to the bathroom real quick oh no are they not here let's
let's give them a second to get their shirt and bask in
their glory of winning all right let's do a countdown oh i
guess all right we're gonna pick donkeys no mousy has to
spin again again oh they're not there no they're not there
okay mousy has to spin again it's very important you show up
to get your prizes number 95 i'm sorry sad your winner's in
my heart what is it what is it 52 there we go 52 number 52
is there number 52
52 I hear someone yelling no did you hear that what you guys
are here guys wild cards show up I literally heard an
anguish no call out for number 52 yeah I think someone was
53 or 51 I'm so sorry we make 51 and 53 fight for it you
guys have the audience muted because I literally heard the
anguish no coming from it.
I think nobody wants my shirt.
Let's spin.
No, no, no.
Let's spin one last time.
One last time.
I'm going to show hope it rolls minus five.
That's my number three.
Come on, come on.
Number three.
It's okay.
Not true, Massey.
They locked out of the paddle room.
They could hear you.
Number 181.
You got to lock it now.
Please, I beg you.
Aren't you here?
181.
Can you pretend you're 182 or 182?
Maybe.
I feel like everyone's looking around.
Everyone's looking around.
Give it a second.
Check your number.
Can we add the 183, the 182 person?
We just like add a number.
We add one.
Plus minus one.
Like, oh no.
Guys, I'm really sorry to think that people are really
avoiding my shirt.
We're doing so well, wildcard.
It's really crazy to see me targeting.
You know what?
I think that just means you're not.
You got two shots.
Is there 182 in the crowd?
Is there still counting off?
I'm begging you, man.
We're going to start counting until there's a- 182.
Is there 182?
Raise your hand if you are 182.
Just go to the bathroom.
180?
Is there 180?
Is there 180 in the crowd?
Are we going to do plus minus two now?
180, which is what we're apparently having to do right now.
183.
Is there a 183 on the crowd?
Any 183s?
Anybody in the 180s?
Do any of you know how to count?
Like, respectfully.
Where are the 180s?
Okay.
We'll come back.
We'll come back on that.
We will come back on that.
We'll give them some time to come back from the box.
Let's do Doki.
Let's do Doki's.
All right.
Last but not least, my share.
Let's do it.
Please don't roll 183.
I'll be really embarrassed.
You better be here.
I'm sitting by in dread now.
I believe, I believe.
Oh, for God's sake.
This can't be!
There's no way!
Nice number.
I was so waiting for six, seven.
I'm not going to lie.
I was so waiting for it.
Right there.
That's my number.
You can just sit down and you don't need a shot.
This is completely random.
Oh my God, guys.
That's me.
Guys, I have the number 69.
No, I'm just joking about it, but he's just actually rigged.
This shirt goes to me.
This is not rigged.
Jokey's just so good like that.
That is crazy.
She's not even the one pressing the wheel button.
Is there a 69 in the crowd?
Maybe it is my shirt.
Come on.
It's an unforgettable number.
All right.
Okay.
I'll go with the next.
If there's no 69 in the crowd, is there a 67?
Is there a 67?
Yeah.
Who wants 67, man?
What?
oh my god to cancel the panel do you guys think oh my you
can't write this you cannot that's this is gonna go down in
like club law for like the rest of eternity of course it was
when the wheel incident happened guys god gives me great
comedic timing i don't know what to say i don't you disgust
me you disgust me i'm just so happy it was dokey like it was
if it could have been anyone else.
Joki got 69 and 67.
It's art.
And it's the front row too.
The front row.
Okay, we're going to do rock, paper, scissors for the three
people in the 180s number in order to get Mouse's shirt.
Oh, yeah.
Or a couple people in the 180s range.
All right, go to the main stage.
Stand on the main stage.
If you want to battle, yeah.
if you want to battle if you want to forfeit don't forfeit
if you want to forfeit uh you can see you can you can do
that but if you want to battle go to the main stage yeah go
to the main stage fight for the shirt people on stream don't
worry we'll commentate it so they're coming out they're
walking up now they're walking on stage or the aura yeah you
want to guys do you guys want to commentate this like sport
oh wait it's four people so they should do one v one and
then the winners of that should face each other okay okay
he's like planning the tournament as it's going on right now
yeah yeah all right one v one each of you one v one each
other the one v one yeah yeah we're gonna give you a cue
like rock paper scissors yeah we'll give you a cue all right
oh mousy should do it mousy should do it yeah okay you cue
them in oh okay i'm ready oh wait i think they're already
perished.
A brilliant soldier fell.
Okay, let Massey queued this one up, guys.
Don't do it until Massey does it.
There we started.
No, no, no, no.
Ah!
It's a winner!
The world is about not following the rules.
We don't listen to the captains.
Oh, it's because the captains are already not listening to
it.
Congratulations on your show, you monster.
There's a little bit of scuff.
That's what's happening.
There's a little bit of scuff to the live feed, though.
Oh, yeah.
We can blame me.
Sorry.
Oopsie.
for your tea you said congratulations actually it's on the
wildcard club rin how could you you're chewing the wires i
see you people say i'm not good at being in the wildcard
club just because i'm a british orphan who eats coal more oh
man can you say the chimney you go you british orphan where
are you doing more wires please no i don't know what that
means more wires please sir yes
Yes.
What was the World Cup Club meant to be again?
We're going to circle back to one of the other slides just
to refresh your memory after the super fun, awesome of...
Now you have your shorts, right?
Or battle we saw.
Now that we saw the great battle, that was the battle
Royale's talking about.
Yeah.
We're going to go back and just re-talk about our
directions.
It's rewind time.
Our individual songs.
Rewind time.
Not to be confused with a dokey rewind time.
Yeah, dokey, dokey rewind time.
are we doing we should we should switch it up a little bit
and do right to left yeah you go ahead all right so for my
team our team's gonna be the loudest and most energetic unit
out there we're here to cause chaos and everything and it
sounds yeah guys gonna be so fun why do you say that like
it's a threat yeah we will have fun if you don't have fun i
kick you out
Yeah, I give them a little survey after each session.
It's like, are you having fun?
Please check yes or no.
No, that's it.
It's over.
I take you out.
No, I'm on Mission Wildcard.
No.
I would take you out to the bar and upstate.
Yes.
Don't worry.
You'll be safe on my team.
If you join my team, I'll keep you safe from Doki.
But I do guarantee that we'll make amazing music.
Music is a huge part of my background and all of that.
my content, as you know.
So if you join my team, we're going to make some amazing
song together.
I'm so excited to work with you.
So please join my team.
You're going to do great.
I promise.
I'm so excited.
For me, if you join my team, I am 1 million percent sure
that I'm going to have a ton of awesome people because I
want to have fun and I want to have a ton of cool people and
people that I think are great.
And I think you guys are all great.
Everybody's great.
We're all great.
Yeah.
Everybody's great.
It's gonna be fun.
I'm excited.
And my team is gonna be the one that drains the club's
budget the most because I'm mostly just gonna be spending my
allowance on biscuits and magnesium.
Vote for me.
Wait, they said that was my job.
Oh, is this not the mayoral election?
Oh, sorry.
Wait a minute.
They said I can use up the budget.
You had budget rights?
Everything's falling on my desk.
See, that's why you can't be trusted.
Wait, what's that supposed to mean, huh?
That's the act of sounds of money laundering.
You can't trust that.
Don't mind, Bob.
Oh my God, this is like a you get, you know, this is like
voting ads.
Join my team and you'll get a wild club card.
That's my promise.
Oh, wow.
But no matter whose team you join, you're in for so much
fun.
We would all obviously love to have you on our individual
teams, but it does not matter who you choose.
But the applications are open right now.
Yeah.
Can we mention that?
Go now.
select the captains you want to go in you can select uh you
have to select actually who you want to uh join whose team
you want to join uh and uh recruitment runs exactly for one
month from today until august 26th uh you can easily apply
via the on-screen qr code that you see right here above uh
mouse and dokey look up look up guys look at the qr code is
right behind me isn't it official website again, guys.
Oh, it's a test.
What's there?
Yeah, guys.
Yeah, what is, yeah, guys.
This was the quiz for the orientation.
Audience, what's the official website?
You're meant to be the leader.
You should know this.
No, also be available on the official Twitter account as
well, I'm sure.
So you can find it there as well.
But yeah, have so much fun in your applications.
We're going to move on to one of the other slides as well
but we look forward to seeing your applications yes this is
an online event happening does it someone want to talk about
this um i nominate rin no no pressure on me oh not me oh no
no no i don't know if i can handle this oh this is a lot
okay okay uh everybody who's watching online is a club
member as well so we're giving everybody walkers if you head
on over to the wild club clip
listen guys i only slept one hour okay yes you're doing so
good you're doing great the website there's an event where
you can decorate and display your own personal locker and
those who come first get the earlier locker numbers and you
know i i like early numbers you know it's really You feel
like you're a family member, you know?
Yippee!
Yay!
We'd love to see your designs.
Yeah, and you remember to tag the Twitter account, the
Wildcard Club Twitter account, or use the hashtag, too, and
share on Twitter.
Wait, did we mention the winner, the winner that's being
drawn on July 28th?
No, but you can mention it.
There is a winner!
There's a winner going to be chosen from those that design
their lockers.
It's going to be chosen on July 28th.
So if you want to win.
You better give it your best designs.
Oh, I see a jokie locker already on the slide.
Oh, there's some really cool lockers online.
The official Twitter's been like retweeting them and stuff.
So you can go check out the competition.
They're very interactive, I saw.
Yeah, they're really cool.
So creative.
No, please don't turn me into a marketable locker.
No!
Yes, turn me into a marketable locker.
I like that.
It's scary, I don't know.
all right what's next oh all right this time i nominate rin
yeah let's go rin okay i could i could do this i could um
you got it you got this come on hello club okay i think i
got the point across we're gonna have an after party
congratulations i'm congratulating myself because i'm
hosting it gonna be an after party it's gonna be on the 28th
we'll tell you the winners of the locker thing are it's
gonna be great yes anything is possible believe in yourself
uh what time did we say it was gonna be again because we all
live in 500 different times 10 a.m pt pst yeah that yeah
that was the one i don't remember pt which is 1 p.m et yeah
pt to bst converter That's so great, guys.
Yeah, and that's on, and it's gonna be hosted on Rin and
Amelie's channels.
So, yeah, Rin on YouTube, my channel on Twitch.
So it's at RinPedros over on YouTube or at Amelie over on
Twitch.
And that'll be 10 a.m.
PT on the 28th or 1 p.m.
ET on the 28th.
Hope to see you there.
All right, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're gonna talk more about like our event.
Oh, Mousy can tell our stories of Korea.
Yeah, I could.
Oh my God.
We YouTube said that's where we're finally gonna tell the
stories now that we revealed everything yeah we have some
photos to share and some other fun now we can talk about
john hybe and then we can do more q a's if we need to if
anyone's still confused we can use the after parties a way
for you guys to ask us more questions and stuff so make sure
to show up at the off guy after party live stream i'm rin
and amelie's channel yeah yeah yeah Looking forward to it.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
And who wants to mention this?
I guess I haven't said anything yet.
Go ahead.
Oh, I get the shortest one too.
Yeah.
That's right.
Oh, you.
So episode two is coming out today.
Actually, in like seven minutes, actually.
Oh, that one does.
Yeah, it's seven minutes after this orientation.
Make sure to check out episode two on YouTube.
the wildcard club channel to learn more about the wildcard
and if you missed episode one congratulations uh we've got a
solution for that it's called watching episode one marathon
time that's a great it'll be a very small marathon like
maybe but you know get up to speed it'll be grand all right
do you have anything else um oh uh oh yeah hold on you guys
before we end the panel over at Offka if you happen to be
there in person we're going to be doing a a cute photo all
together so um if you're in the audience uh please like put
up a cute hand sign and look backwards because the the venue
staff is going to take a photo of behind so we're gonna be
on the screen so look behind you like over your shoulder
he's right behind you do anything you could do anything yeah
it could be your hands up can be a peace sign can be heart
hands yeah do whatever you want to do this is our first
orientation let's make this really memorable So our very
first group photo together with the captains of the wildcard
club.
Yippee!
You're the only one who came for press.
Okay, we're gonna do a photo countdown.
Let's do...
Oh, wait.
Do I need to do it or...
Yeah, I nominate and I'm...
I'm Lee.
Okay, I'll do it.
Ready?
Everybody smile on one.
I'm gonna do 10 to one.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, two
did we get it hello guys now i can't see anything okay we're
gonna take a couple photos we're gonna take a couple photos
we'll do we'll do five seconds i'm stuck like this forever
that's okay we're gonna do another one oh four three two one
wild card club yeah the what all right cute cute okay last
one let's do a silly one the last one this time for real
guys let's do a silly one after you say one after one we say
wildcard club together how about that cute cute yeah i like
it i like it yeah yeah after one we say wildcard club okay
five four three two one wildcard club cute yeah love it love
it we actually match you get through everything we did it we
did it it's a christmas miracle we were so nervous for
joining oh if you were one of the four raffle winners please
stay behind afterwards by the way so don't leave uh please
stay behind so that's if you haven't got your shirt um yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're stuck in forever now the shot
seals your face oh my gosh i'm so excited this is like the
start of the journey of our journey here at the wildcard
club we're already here i can't know right scary scary and
yet well i'm super excited to work on music and hang out
with you guys to me i'm interested to see who's gonna apply
yeah you the viewer yeah i can't wait to see who's gonna be
on our teams and everything and um i gosh i guess we'll see
you at the clubhouse yeah don't forget to come by and take
photos with us at the booth yeah How do we end this?
How do we?
Do we just like, do we have a club outro?
Or like, do we just say welcome to the club?
Like, do you know what?
Pop it says, welcome to the club.
Okay, right.
Yeah, you're on account of, but Emily, you're so good at
countdowns now.
Yeah, you can.
Three, two, one, three, two, one.
And then on the beat of the fourth number, then we do,
welcome to the club.
Like, like, like anime dubbing.
No, okay, anyways, okay.
Three.
You referenced.
Three, two, one.
Welcome.
Club
All right, I'll get out of here.
Scram Bye